mineros a pedradas contra la senadora
boliviana Cecilia requena en el río Beni
fue durante una visita a las dragas de
minería ilegal dentro del Parque
Nacional más biodiverso del mundo está
en el departamento de la paz en la
minería en Bolivia está completamente
descontrolado Bolivia es el principal
importador mundial de mercurio este es
necesario para la minería de oro salvaje
práctica que ha aumentado en los últimos
cinco años en la amazonía boliviana
[Música]
el uso del mercurio en la minería tiene
severos impactos en la protección del
medio ambiente la deforestación y
especialmente en los derechos de los
pueblos indígenas que son contaminados
por las aguas que utilizan para el
saneamiento y especialmente por los
peces que comen en los ríos que se han
contaminado con Mercurio
como ya ha pasado en Perú y Brasil la
tensión aumentada entre mineros y
comunidades indígenas estos últimos han
visto cómo ha cambiado su vida
sabemos también que utiliza mercurio y
no entonces
verdaderamente está totalmente
contaminado ya el frío no se puede Ni
bañarse de tomar como antes se hacía nos
pescabamos los pescados que ahí en el
río no en los peces
el precio del oro ha aumentado a nivel
global y en paralelo la minería ilegal
esta se oculta en el Amazonas el pulmón
del mundo que con estas prácticas ve
contaminadas sus arterias